lots to talk to Jim McMahon about so
this morning's Shadow environment
secretary hi it's good to see you good
morning can we start with Sudan yeah of
course
um airlift underway we believed um how
embarrassing is it or not at all that we
had to rely on Germany and France to
bring out Brits before this
well I mean I wouldn't say it's
embarrassing in a sense that we're going
to use this window during the ceasefire
to bring back as many British Nationals
as possible uh clearly our primary
consideration is for the people who were
there who are fearful for their safety
and the cost family here who are fearful
full of ones who were in Sudan so in
terms of our cross-party support for
that effort it's absolutely there as
with all these things that there will be
a look back
um at some point and that will bring
into Pro whether the response was quick
enough it will compare it to other
countries and that will run its course
but the primary consideration now is
using that window of the ceasefire okay
um let me ask you that question in a
different way um after the 72 hours when
that window closes in theory
um do we then revert to other countries
bringing out our Nationals well we rely
on the foreign office and the mod to
assess what's safe what we don't want to
do is to place uh civilians in a
situation where even for the best intent
in trying to extract them to bring them
back here to the UK they're placed in a
position where they're unsafe and so we
need to rely on the foreign office and
the ministry of Defense to do that and
really just make the most of that window
we now got where we have a better degree
if you like of safety talk to me about
forcing a vote on the water bill sewers
you want to clean up our water systems
uh doesn't everybody but um the
conservatives are saying the government
is saying that if we did what labor is
suggesting our water bills would go up
threefold well I mean listen labor has
cleaned up the Tory mess before when we
came into government our Waters were
dirt when labor left office they were
the cleanestness before the Industrial
Revolution so that's our record
and what people want to know is that the
place where they live where they work
and where their holiday are being
treated with respect people want to know
that when their child is building a sand
castle on the beach that it's safe for
them to do that and not that there's raw
human sewage being pumped out at a rate
of knots and that's what's happening at
the moment our Rivers our lakes and our
seas are being completely disrespected
now we've been pushing the government
for over a year to comfort with a plan
that's credible that holds water and
will end the tourist sewage Scandal and
they fail to do that so today we're
moving our own bill that would end the
sui Scandal by 20 footer it's
deliverable it's affordable and actually
the water companies as well as the
campaigners say this is exactly what
they've been waiting to see
excuse me I almost sneeze um yeah but to
answer my question is it going to put is
it going to increase our water bills by
300 well the tours will banned around
these figures and they do give me the
right figure but they just don't hold
any scrutiny uh off what the financial
regulator so the water companies have
existing resources when you open your
water bill you will see there you are
paying for sewage to be treated and the
fact is it's not being treated so there
wouldn't be an increase in our water
bills at all for this measure off what
have been clear the water companies have
existing Resources by their owners
anymore in our waterfalls but people are
paying now
we've been very clear that with an
existing resources there is money let's
bear in mind is privatization so it's
privatization you're not being here
that's why I'm requesting it does let me
answer the question it says
privatization 72 billion pound has been
taken out in dividend payments it
wouldn't cost even half of that to put
right the sewage Scandal so if there's
enough to take out nearly 2 billion
pound every year in profit they really
don't want money to put right this
problem so would you how would you make
that work if you were in government
we've been very clear that's got to come
from that profit the profit's got to be
squeezed because you can't draw around
billions of profit if you're not fixing
the water system you're a water company
in the water industry one by having a
legally binding Target to reduce all
discharges by 20 uh 30. having Financial
systems in place so actually water
companies understand not taking action
is more expensive than taking action at
the moment so you would penalize them
fine absolutely Financial penalties
automatic penalties so the second sewage
is discharged the payment meter starts
running and if there's no monitor in
place then we'll make sure there's a
stand-in charge assuming that water
companies are dumping anyway way that
will change Behavior it will drive
investment and finally we will end the
tourist Jewish candle okay talk to me
about before I let you go as a voter ID
um it's five o'clock this afternoon if
you've not got any photo ID otherwise
you can't register to oh you can't go
and vote
is that fair
what we see with the conservatives that
they want to decrease the number of
people who feel motivated to vote and
who can vote labor doesn't think that's
the right approach but we need to be
clear that many people who don't support
voter ID well we don't think that the
evidence supports there being a problem
it's a sledgehammer to crack a nut the
instance is a broader fraud uh minute
compared to the impact that this will
have so we don't think it's a
proportionate response but we're also
saying to people listen uh prepare to
vote don't allow this to put you off if
you have the ID that allows you to vote
then do vote make sure if you've not got
the ID that you meet the deadlines that
you can vote and listen if the tour is
really one to deny you your opportunity
to cast your Democratic right to vote
then don't allow them the opportunity
and make sure that people register
Before I Let You Go you're happy sitting
on the benches with Diana
but listen uh Kia has been very clear
that the comments that were made are you
happy sitting on the benches with
Jack well you know okay that in any
disciplinary action and that's currently
what we're going through on the benches
Diane will be allowed to make a case the
party will assess that and they'll come
to a conclusion uh about what's the
right response I'm very happy for the uh
the labor party complaint system to
allow so that's a yes governance course
and for that to conclude but in terms of
the comments the comments weren't
acceptable kirstan was being clear they
were unacceptable
so she's an anti-semite according to
your leader are you happy sitting on the
bench as well it's important that the
disciplinary process the complaints
process is allowed to run its course in
terms of the comments we've been
absolutely clear that they cannot stand
absolutely Diane was very clear in her
apology to that but she has got to
account for why They'll Come Into Summer
according to your boss are you happy
City why those comments existed are you
happy sitting with them they did I
wouldn't be happy to sitting next to a
Nancy Semite but you know as I know the
minute any disciplinary action is
undertaken with an aparter uh it's not
for anybody to comment uh it's going to
allow it it's cold or an anti-semite
well the comments were clearly uh
unacceptable
good to see you thank you